avait de l'été à quelques semaines des
vacances de juillet une grave question
se pose pour les femmes et pour les
hommes également ce au moins qu'ils ont
droit aux chèvres voix au chapitre êtes
vous une pièce ou deux pièces autrement
dit êtes-vous bikini ou maillots de bain
pu traditionnel nathalie jourdan raymond
chapelât ils répondent devenir des
centres de la saison objectif flairé la
tendance
chaque été c'est le même casse-tête
doit-on se dénuder un peu beaucoup pas
du tout réponse des pros du maillot ce
sont d'abord les bikinis pareille sortie
bikini avec pishyar bertone le orange
couleur soleil évidemment
alors pour les arts nous avons également
les boxers très sexy qui sont très très
beaux qu'ils vont tous très près aux
orres le bonhomme en boxer donc la
sirène en bikini on peut aussi chercher
l'inspiration ailleurs c'est les
couleurs chamarrées des belles
couvertures
en france aussi les filets des
vainqueurs valérie de filaments majorité
juan les pins
le temple de la mode estivale le roi
dans les malheurs de bar sans vendre aux
états unis c'est très soirée un peu non
le maillot de soirée pas encore un must
le string a pris du plomb dans l aile
mais la ficelle garde tout de même ses
inconditionnels si je pouvais rien le
titre encore mieux c'est sûr ne rien
mettre c'est encore la meilleure
solution pour éviter de commettre la
faute de goût qui vous pourrit votre été
dernières consignes elle vient d'un sage
des plages de fait refuser la vente dans
là je peux peut-être nui vous secourir
par 40 s'intégrer c'est pas toujours
évident jeunes et moins jeunes cet été
sur la plage c'est surtout comme vous le
sentez